[Music]
being an adult doesn't have to mean
you're stuck giving and receiving boring
practical gifts forget the tie is in the
bath sets help your loved ones embrace
their inner child here's a list of fun
geeky goods that will make them feel
like a kid again first up is Dead Rising
4 Dead Rising 4 is the perfect gift for
the zombie lover or for fans of the Dead
Rising series in the fourth installment
Frank West returns to Willamette
Colorado during the holiday season
players will explore a vast open-world
sandbox filled with zombies and a
million ways to kill them and friends
can enjoy a multiplayer match and try to
survive a night in the willamette mall
Dead Rising 4 is available for Xbox one
and Windows 10 PC give a friend an
escape from reality with an oculus rift
help your friends slip into a virtual
reality with their very own oculus rift
headset VR is unlike anything you've
ever experienced and you don't need to
be a gamer to appreciate it step into a
game watch a movie or travel the world
all from the comfort of your own home
make sure they have a Windows PC in
order to use the rift quality VR comes
with a hefty price tag the oculus rift
will set you back $600
speaking of PC gaming we have a couple
of recommendations for the PC gamer in
your life first you'll need a good
gaming mouse
we recommend the logitech g502 this high
performance gaming mouse precisely
translates your hand movements on screen
with an advanced optical gaming sensor
the g502 is well reviewed and known for
its comfort and build quality the g502
retails for $79.99 or you can opt for a
new stylish gaming keyboard with the
corsair strafe RGB Corsairs strafe RGB
mechanical gaming keyboard looks and
feels great it's textured and contoured
keycaps make typing comfortable and easy
it's multi color backlighting is fully
adjustable and works with hundreds of
downloadable lighting effects the strafe
RGB retails for 130 $9.99 how about a
versatile gaming headset that works with
PC and consoles
check out the HyperX cloud stinger the
HyperX cloud singer prides itself on its
lightweight comfort and sound quality
this headset has rotating ear cups with
memory foam who's also volume control on
the headset ear cup and a swivel to mute
noise cancelling mic best of all it's
compatible with multiple platforms
PC Xbox one ps4 and we you get it for
$49.99 you're never too old to like
aliens ninjas dinosaurs or zombies all
these and more included and smash up
smash up is a fun shuffle building car
game where each player combines two
factions into one deck use a team of
robots and dinosaurs or wizards and
pirates and compete to smash the most
spaces I've owned this for months and I
still love playing it for the variety of
teams and matchups it's easy to learn
and you can play with two to four
players get smash up for $29.99 and once
you get tired of the factions in the
first set there are quite a few
expansions like the science-fiction
double feature set for 22 and 99 if
you're looking for a great organ to give
a loved one I recommend pandemic
pandemic is a co-op board game where two
to four players team up to save the
world for diseases have broken out
across the planet and it's up to your
team to find cures before outbreaks
occur and mankind is wiped out this game
is exciting immersive and I love being
able to work together with your fellow
players pandemic retails for $39.99 next
up is @y I've always wanted and still
want as an adult the Lego Star Wars
Millennium Falcon who doesn't want their
own Millennium Falcon the latest version
of this Lego set comes with updated
features and minifigures from the force
awakens it's got a detachable cockpit
rotating laser turrets detailed
hyperdrive how a chessboard and a secret
compartment get the Millennium Falcon
building kit for one $49.99 Funko pop
figures are becoming more and more
popular these cuties are all over the
desks here at GameSpot add to your
friends collection or start them off
with Funko's Street Fighter collector's
set take your friends back to their
fighting game routes with these classic
Street Fighter characters the set comes
with Ryu Ken Blancas and chun-li ready
to stand guard in your cubicle or on
your living room shelf plus they're
adorable get the Street Fighter
collector set from Funko on Amazon for
$37.99 if you're looking for a
budget-friendly gift how about these
sweet Power Rangers mugs these are
officially licensed Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers themed mugs you can choose from
the Red Ranger or the Pink Ranger these
ceramic mugs hold a surprisingly large
twenty ounces of liquid each and they're
BPA and toxin free each Power Rangers
mug is $14.99
if you've ever wanted to be mega man
you're a step closer with Capcom's Mega
Man wearable helmet replica this
official full-sized Megaman helmet is
made of high-quality plastic with a
polished finish as a clamshell hinge
which allows the helmet to open up it
comes with adjustable velcro interior
foam to fit comfortably over your head
put it on display or use it for cosplay
this Mega Man helmet retails for 150
$9.99 and that's our list of top gifts
for big kids brought to you by Dead
Rising 4 happy gifting and Happy
Holidays I'm chastity and I'll see you
next time
[Music]